c'est un nouveau départ pour la jeune
boxeuse victime d'un accident de la
route en février son rêve olympique
s'effondrait mais c'était sans compter
sur sa force de caractère ça va beaucoup
mieux depuis l'accident ça a été un peu
ça a été un peu compliqué de revenir sur
le coup la chance viendra ensuite de la
malchance d'Émilie son Vico du Boxing
Club du zees éliminé en quart de finale
des jeux européens c'était fin juin en
Pologne alors pas de vacances cet été
pour victoire un retour à l'entraînement
très progressif on s'entraîne pas
pendant un certain temps où on est
habitué de s'entraîner deux fois par
jour physiquement quand on veut
reprendre c'est un peu plus dur donc bah
ça vient taper dans le moral on se dit
il y a un mois je faisais ça facile et
là c'est tout pareil hyper compliqué
donc on se remet en question elle est
convoquée pour un stage d'une semaine
avec l'équipe de France et combattra
samedi prochain contre l'équipe
nationale de Cuba elle se prépare dans
des conditions qui ne sont pas celles
d'une possible athlètes olympique ça
serait bien un jour d'avoir
pouvoir à l'heure où on va faire du
sparine la salle soit dispo c'est vrai
que de voir toujours partager
des fois il y a des moments où je peux
pas venir m'entraîner en fait Sébastien
son père est entraîneur est convaincu
des capacités de victoire et la prépare
à gravir les marches vers une
qualification olympique victoire a été
remplie pour un premier stage puis un
second puis un troisième ça veut dire
que je pense que la première fois on l'a
appelé pour la tester la deuxième fois
la semer le doute et puis maintenant
nous d'aller faire la différence et
cette différence c'est d'abord
l'expérience de 4 années en boxe
professionnelle et d'autres points forts
je pense que c'est un peu la force de
frappe je pense que c'est une force que
j'ai je suis gauchère ça plaît pas à
tout le monde l'objectif est d'être
sélectionné pour le dernier tournoi de
qualification fin février en Italie et
d'atteindre les demi-finales pour
décrocher le précieux ticket pour Paris